Nadia elle est où à l'euro
toujours chez eux toujours chez eux
effectivement
et toujours chez eux mais j'ai tendance
à dire non Cyril elle est toujours chez
elle alors il y a une décision du préfet
île du préfet allergalité des chances
des Bouches-du-Rhône qui donne raison au
couple Nadia doit s'en aller mais
simplement monsieur maître et là c'est
pour ça que je voulais vous interpeller
je suis en colère contre vous vous avez
vous en plus
auprès du tribunal administratif en fait
vous voulez encore du temps des délais
et j'ai l'impression que Nadia
finalement elle ne veut pas quitter le
domicile bravo est-ce que c'est vrai
que Nadja a moins de droit que vous non
j'ai pas dit ça
au moment où il y a une décision
du préfet je vous pose simplement cette
question est-ce que vous pensez que
notre armoire que vous vous m'avez
invité ce soir je vous remercie et
d'ailleurs oui moi je le redis Hervé
qu'on soit d'accord avec ou pas Hervé
fait son métier bien sûr un avocat ça
veut dire qu'il fait bien son métier
voilà lui il a des figures décidé de
défendre Nadia et je suis désolé et donc
Hervé il fait son boulot arrêtez oui
merci de me rappeler Cyril donc
aujourd'hui si vous voulez et vous
l'avez juste titre rappelé il y a une
décision du préfet qui a été prise le 28
septembre qui autorise la force publique
à venir déloger l'ado Nadia de son
logement moi ce que j'estime c'est que
cette décision a été prise complètement
sans base légale alors je vais pas
rentrer dans un débat technique je vais
essayer rapidement et expliquer à nos
téléspects parce que personne ne
comprend pourquoi il y a une décision de
justice et pourquoi elle est encore dans
le logement de justice alors là ça a été
signé par le préfet alors du préfet
n'est pas une décision du 6 mais on va
on va essayer de démocratiser des choses
et de pas être technique pour que ce
soit compréhensible pour tout le monde
si vous voulez une décision est
intervenue par le tribunal de Marseille
cette décision est en date du 28 avril
2022 d'accord cette décision que j'ai
communiqué peut-être la régie à la
communiquer peut-être que la saisie la
régie cette fois-ci va la prendre vous
allez voir que dans le dispositif d'une
décision de la décision c'est pas
celle-ci celle-ci c'est celle d'une
c'est la décision préférée
non c'est pas celle-ci non plus
dites-moi vous êtes arrivé avec un
dossier comme ça
alors on a alors c'est le dispositif de
la décision qui stipule c'est tout ce
qui nous a été envoyé pardon
alors
la disposition le dispositif de cette
décision le dispositif d'une décision
c'est finalement une fois que le juge
explique la situation d'accord ce qu'il
ressort de sa décision donc dans le
dispositif il est clairement noté que
Nadia doit être expulsé ça on dit ce
qu'on vient pas il y a aucune difficulté
sur cela mais elle doit être expulsée
sous un délai de quatre mois à compter
de la notification du commandement de
quitter les lieux donc c'était quand ça
on est le 28 on est le 19 avril 19 mai
pardon
2022 d'accord on est en mai 2022 j'y
arrive en septembre donc c'est
maintenant lorsque Nadia va recevoir
cette notification par le biais d'un
huissier et là en revanche vous l'avez
c'est le document qui était juste avant
cette notification voilà vous l'avez
c'est le 13 mai
vous voyez que l'huissier
le 13 mai c'est la fête je suis désolé
je vous en prie c'est le 13 mai c'est la
date à laquelle l'huissier et vous le
voyez en haut va signifier une
ordonnance de référé alors déjà c'est
faux c'est pas une ordonnance de
référence une décision ça c'est la
première problématique la deuxième
problématique vous voyez que le délai
que va laisser l'huissier en Nadia pour
quitter les lieux n'est pas de 4 mois
mais de deux mois au plus tard le 13
juillet exactement c'est quoi ça ça a
été repris ça alors vous allez le voir
de toute façon en dessous c'était joint
a priori
existe et dans tous les cas de figure
vous voyez que juste au dessus d'accord
il est noté en lettres cette fois-ci
dans un délai de deux mois deux mois
alors on le voit pas parce que
voilà donc exactement donc du 13 juillet
donc c'est 13 septembre parce que 13 ans
donc si vous voulez quand je dis Verdez
que Nadia n'a pas moins de droit que
vous lorsque vous recevez une
notification d'un commandement qui était
des lieux qui ne correspond pas à ce que
la décision de justice a prévu je suis
désolé mais ce commandement est nul
d'ailleurs vous faites votre travail
d'avocats de la justice
est tellement convaincu cette
démonstration que finalement le 19 août
et là encore vous avez la pièce le 19
août il va redélivrer un nouveau congé
vous le voyez ce nouveau congé le 9 le
19 août qui est à droite d'accord voilà
merci donc il doit faire si vous voulez
un nouveau congé et vous allez au dessus
ce qui a écrit annuler en place la
signification du 11 août parce que juste
avant il y en avait un autre non mais
moi
je comprends je comprends tout à fait
que vous fassiez votre travail et vous
le faites bien c'est super maintenant
Nadia nous a dit qu'elle est partir il y
a une décision du préfet ils ont fait
voilà ils ont ils ont fait les choses
elle veut partir quand alors c'est ça
qui veulent savoir noter les spectateurs
il est 20h45 on est en direct il y a le
parc par contre alors on a déjà si vous
voulez elle compte quitter ce logement
mais quand mais moi je peux pas vous
répondre aussi je compte beaucoup
il faut pas me recadrer les choses si je
peux me permettre déjà ici à la demande
de cou Garcia d'accord qui ont décidé de
médiatiser l'affaire c'est pas elle qui
200 initiative
quelle est en train de rechercher un
autre logement
elle avait pas l'air les époux qui
étaient ici avaient dit que depuis elle
n'a pas cherché à trouver un autre
logement si elle ne cherche pas c'est en
ça que ne montre pas de volonté
de cache-cache qui dit alors c'est ce
qu'on appelle la différence entre
écouter une seule partie et le principal
contradictoire mais juste d'accord mais
donc là aujourd'hui vous avez
aujourd'hui il faut trouver une solution
alors aujourd'hui est-ce que est-ce
qu'il y a les forces de l'ordre qui sont
venus aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui les
forces de notre menu ils ont prévenu
Nadia que finalement ça allait être
imminent d'accord ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que mon cabinet a déposé hier
pendant le weekend donc on a peu dormi
ce qu'on appelle un référé de liberté un
référé de liberté c'est une procédure
exceptionnelle que le tribunal
administratif nous permet et qui tant à
faire suspendre la décision du préfet
quant à la mise en place des forces de
l'ordre pour pouvoir déloger l'adja
parce que j'estime et c'est parfaitement
argumenté on verra d'accord que cette
décision du préfet en frein des libertés
fondamentales de Nadia vous allez gagner
du temps enfin vous allez gagner du
temps en fait
je vais me reprocher quoi finalement de
faire mon métier de faire son boulot
dans ce cas-là il fallait penser avant
le philosophe pas un avocat alors juste
Hervé je vous le dis maître c'est
incroyable nous ce qu'on veut on veut
des réponses voilà il était spectateurs
ils disent on veut savoir Nadia elle par
contre
alors encore une fois je vais
malheureusement répéter ce que je viens
de vous dire moi je suis arrivé sur
aussi
alors moi pour moi aujourd'hui encore
une fois parce que vous vous incitez sur
la question et vous voulez une réponse
et j'entends finalement que vous faites
bien votre travail d'animateur et et
c'est pour faire votre travail d'avocat
et c'est pour ça je vous aime beaucoup
et je vous montre d'ailleurs tous les
soirs mais moi aussi je trouve excellent
attends
incroyable franchement
ça sera avec grand plaisir non non mais
les mecs lui il fait son boulot alors
il faut comprendre Gilles le reste c'est
que la procédure que j'entends à un
autre lancement sous 48 heures d'accord
c'est un autre chanson sous 48 heures
donc ça veut dire qu'on va pas tomber
d'un anal et moi j'ai confiance en cette
procédure parce qu'elle a annulé la
décision du préfet finalement j'allais
dire qu'est-ce qui nous empêche
aujourd'hui d'attendre c'est 48 heures
concrètement la réalité elle est là
aujourd'hui si finalement on a déjà une
raison pour en rester dans son logement
parce que l'addition du préfet va être
annulé si elle a pas dans quel point
rester dans son logement c'est ça votre
objectif
pour essayer d'aller
partir
elle veut plus partir
il y a deux possibilités soit dans tous
les cas de figure dans tous les cas de
figure elle vous l'a dit sur ce plateau
la semaine dernière elle veut partir
d'accord maintenant c'est moi aussi je
veux faire un régime
il y a deux possibilités il y a partir
dignement dans des conditions où on lui
retrouve un logement et à qui on lui
propose un hébergement
un hébergement qui est un appart hôtel
pendant deux mois vous avez une
information que je n'ai pas mais en
l'occurrence si vous voulez si déjà
cette possibilité existe pourquoi pas on
a dit
on a dit qu'on pouvait l'aider Nadia
voilà on a dit qu'on pouvait l'aider
nous un ou deux mois voilà avec la
production maximum parce qu'après je
vais mettre la clé sous la porte euh
voilà Nadia pour qu'elle parte le plus
vite possible donc voilà donc elle peut
elle pourrait se mettre d'accord avec
nous qu'on la reloche pour un ou deux
mois comme ça le gagne du temps mais
deux mois et après comme ça pierre et
Maryse peuvent venir dans le logement
cette semaine alors encore une fois je
vais peut-être redondant mais je vais
vous dire ce que je pense soit on est
dans un pays de droit soit l'un des
appuis le moral
aujourd'hui si vous voulez je suis
avocat de Nadia je représente ces
intérêts et je fais en sorte entre
guillemets que la loi soit respectée
donc force est de constater que si cette
procédure devant le Tribunal
Administratif venez à prospérer dans la
réalité celle qui respecte la loi
aujourd'hui ça serait Nadia ne vous en
déplaise
en revanche n'hésite pas qu'elle veut
pas vous elle est dans son droit mais ne
dites pas en revanche oui elle veut
partir parce qu'elle veut pas partir
conduire une possibilité même de deux
mois ou 3 mois peut-être avec Cyril elle
dit non ça prouve bien que non elle ne
veut pas alors je ne fais que vous a dit
sur ce plateau à savoir qu'elle
souhaitait partir parce qu'il y a un
enfer oui alors alors aujourd'hui les
personnes moins que Pierre et Marie
encore une fois ne se compare pas
d'accord non non mais les misères ne
sont pas
forcément mais la maladie vous la
connaissez pas donc
la maladie des deux personnes ils ont
déclaré la maladie vous la connaissez
pas donc je pense qu'à un moment donné
il faut aussi savoir garder raison non
mais là là aujourd'hui juste mettre si
vous nous rejoignez il est poussé cette
rue là il est 20h50
les Chéries juste Nadia elle est venue
elle nous a dit qu'elle est partie
il y a eu le préfet on attendait la
signature du préfet il a signé hier
Gilles donc là Gilles avait ses roussi
mettre ses roussi nous dit qu'elle ne
veut pas partir oui en fait ce qui se
passe c'est ça le vrai truc parce que le
préfet il a fait ce qu'il fallait le
préfet il a fait ce qu'il fallait
tardivement il a signé il l'a fait la
force publique est prête à agir mais
votre manœuvre c'est une manœuvre
dilatoire pour gagner du temps monsieur
vous défendez votre cliente mais
dites-nous vraiment dites à tous les
gens qui nous regardent les yeux dans
les yeux Nadia elle ne veut pas partir
et si vous gagnez au tribunal elle ne
partira pas petite question si il y a la
signature du préfet et qu'on arrive à la
trêve hivernale est-ce qu'elle part
quand même où est-ce que c'est alors si
à la signature du préfet il faut que ce
soit exécuté avant la trêve sinon c'est
mort absolument donc vous essayez de
gagner jusqu'à bientôt mais oui mais
bien sûr
encore une fois je vais je vais
peut-être encore une fois me répéter je
ne fais que mon travail
me reprocher de faire mon travail
vous n'avez plus
on peut juste dire un truc c'est kervé
il est bon les gars c'est rigoler bah
voilà on peut dire il joue avec les
reconnaître toutes les fans
qui défendent des mecs qui ont fait des
trucs et c'est juste son boulot il fait
son boulot il utilise la loi et il
utilise et voilà les différentes lois
pour pouvoir défendre sa cliente il le
fait bien Siri le pauvre et on peut pas
les tomber dessus excuse-moi
d'intervenir j'utilise même pas la loi
je ne fais que la décision de justice la
décision de justice permanada de se
maintenir dans le logement jusqu'à 4
mois après la signification du
commandement le commandement vous l'avez
vu n'était délivré le 19 août au nom de
quoi partirait avant non mais voilà
4 mois 19 août c'est en plein travail
donc elle partira pas c'est bien ce
qu'on disait correctement avant donc
elle partira si vous voulez je suis pas
attendez
c'est 13 mai il s'en fout lui au
contraire
de ça c'est une erreur
alors voilà mais encore une fois je je
viens à m'expliquer moi aujourd'hui vous
dire que si Nadia veut partir ou pas
c'est pas mon rôle c'est pas mon travail
mon travail c'est de défendre Nadia avec
des éléments juridiques on le met sous
les yeux et on vous en veux pas vous en
vous en veux à elle est ici et qui
manque hôtel de partir parce que dès
qu'on lui donne une possibilité de deux
ou trois mois elle ne la prend pas et
qui dit qu'elle est très gênée par le
fait qu'elle en face elle a des
personnes qui soient malades et qui sont
faibles elles s'en fichent complètement
alors
du travail merci beaucoup de le
reconnaître mais je pense que vous
trompez on a déjà quelqu'un de sensible
du Maine c'est quelqu'un aussi
je vous respecte énormément je respecte
les avocats il y a pas de souci moi si
au mois d'avril je passe devant un
tribunal et on me dit on va expulser je
cherche un appartement vous vous parlez
de 13 mai 17 octobre 14 septembre par
mois moi moi d'avril le tribunal me dit
on va te virer je me barre si c'est
médias je me barre sur toi avec une
fille qu'on attaque sur les réseaux on
attaque ma fille vous rendez compte ça
va être encore pire on va jusqu'au 15
mars en plus il demande de l'aider de
faire son déménagement contrairement à
des gens qui ont besoin qu'on les aide
on va aider Nadia
j'y suis très proche mais finalement qui
fait la justice en France sont les
tribunaux ou les médias et vous vous
avez raison mais vous vous êtes en train
de m'expliquer que finalement parce que
c'est médiatisé
on lui offre trois mois d'hébergement
gratuit maintenant dans cette émission
au lieu de port de sortie qu'est-ce
qu'elle veut de plus maintenant une
voiture à disposition un chauffeur de
plus maintenant excusez-moi monsieur
Delormeau aujourd'hui est-ce que oui ou
non vous pouvez me dire oui que le
commandement de quitter les lieux a été
signé le 19 août de ça
vous offre une solution mais encore une
fois
mettre c'est aussi elle partira jamais
non moi ça pourrait être honnête avec
vous je suis persuadé que la situation
va se décanter très rapidement on va
partir quand alors moi je suis persuadé
et peut-être qu'à ce moment-là vous me
réinviterez ça sera avec plaisir bah
c'est un plaisir pour moi aussi et
est-ce qu'elle va partir avant le 30
octobre alors je vais vous je vais vous
je vais vous dire une chose je suis
persuadé que la partie très rapidement
mais elle souhaite partir dans des
conditions de dignité et je ne suis
persuadé alors
évitez que ce soit des déménageurs qui
fasse sur valise et qu'elle est la
police soit devant chez vous pour vous
inciter à partir si vous vous accrochez
au grille
maintenant encore une fois je le répète
je ne suis pas déjà et je n'ai pas
remarqué
et je vous remercie d'ailleurs pour
votre proposition parce que après tout
vous n'avez pas forcément obligatoire
se termine assez vite oui très vite non
mais mecs qui nous exaspille en fait
c'est qu'il y a un fossé entre les
paroles de Nadia qui nous dit je vais
partir et ses actes on voit qu'elle va
jamais partir et moi j'ai l'impression
qu'elle se fait passer pour une victime
par définition parce qu'elle est
locataires et Pierre et Maryse pour des
gens parce qu'ils sont soi-disant
propriétaire pour des gens qui ne peut
rien atteindre mais c'est le monde à
l'envers en réalité c'est eux qui sont
en galère c'est eux qui sont qui n'ont
pas le logement pendant qu'elle est bien
au chaud aujourd'hui non mais bien sûr
mais il faut qu'on arrête d'avoir de la
pitié pour nasia qu'elle trouve une
solution et qu'elle respecte ses aînés
qui ne veut pas vivre dignement
aujourd'hui contrairement à elle c'est
pas bon à l'envers j'entends
[Applaudissements]
sauf que notre jeune de mon pote pitié
merci
sa première chose heureusement ou pas
mais finalement pas pitié et
deuxièmement encore une fois je suis en
train de vous expliquer c'est que je
vais prochainement vous annoncer je
l'espère que la situation va se décanter
quand c'est quand d'accord
écoutez ça fera peut-être le 3e
rencontre Cyril mais quand vous dites
bientôt c'est ce que ça vaut le 30
octobre moi encore une fois
encore une fois c'est vrai que j'ai bien
joué le match vous avez entendre vous
avez est-ce que ça vaut plus avant oui
d'entendre un bruit de ma bouche je sais
que vous avez entendu mais mais moi
encore une fois je ne suis pas Nadia
donc ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
je fais en sorte que la situation se
décante je fais en sorte qu'elle puisse
partir du moment et après votre émission
d'ailleurs sachez que elle a eu beaucoup
de messages de personnes qui m'ont
proposé un logement et contrairement et
qui ont proposé un logement et qui sont
passés bien mon cabinet pour lui dire
finalement elle a l'air d'être une bonne
locataire et pourquoi pas la rencontre
merci merci alors vous nous avez écouté
en tout cas ça fait 5 ans que baisser le
loyer au bout d'un moment
48 heures dans 48 heures on va voir la
décision alors j'espère que dans 48
heures on aura la décision il y a pas de
raison qu'on les bats puisque finalement
on a on a ce référé liberté qui a été
lancé j'ai eu une accusation une accusée
de réception de l'avocat devant le
tribunal aujourd'hui alors que hier donc
on sera dans on va se redonner des infos
dès demain et après demain mais c'est
vrai que il faut que il faut des dates
merci en tout cas mettre aussi très bon
merci non merci qu'est-ce qu'il y a non
c'était très court mais il paraît que en
plus au moins solder les 1200 euros
qu'elle devait normalement
elle est en train elle est en train de
le faire elle est en train de faire
plein de choses plein de choses en
espérant en tout cas parce qu'on a parce
que je peux pas terminer sur ça la façon
dont vous parlez vous avez l'impression
que c'est une mauvaise payant je
rappelle quand même d'accord
j'entends quand je vous rappelle quand
même quel est l'occasion de plus 5 ans
que tous ces loyers ont été payés et à
jour depuis lors il y a une difficulté
sur le dernier loyer et c'est engagé à
le payer sous le weekend il me semble
pas qu'on est terminé ce délai voilà
tout simplement merci merci